non et vous allez voir interview prise
de tête rené bouchard ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle
j'ai beaucoup parlé bon alors attend une
prise de tête
c'est de votre punition êtes vous
favorable divorce nice à s'imposer à la
liberté sexuelle dans le couple oui à
l'homosexualité à l'adoption d'enfants
par dés couples homosexuels à
l'avortement oui à l'euthanasie et au
suicide
si ça ça me pose et si oui à la peine de
mort pour les assassins d'enfants
oui et est ce que vous êtes savoir le
couloir de bus
mais bon
je m'accroche
les gens les gens ils sont pour
l'avortement le suicide et l'euthanasie
tous les couloirs de bus jamais quelques
emails avant de continuer